One way to reason about this is just to write out all of the strings that this matches--
0, 1, 2--all the way up to 9. Ten different 1-digit strings.
Zero is certainly in this set, so 0 matches 0 through 9.
One matches 0 through 9. Remember the interpretation is everything
between and including the beginning up to and including the end.
Ten, however, is a 2-letter string. It's too big.
This regular expression only matches ten strings that are each 1 letter long.
This one doesn't match. Similarly, 11 is just too large.
05 is very tempting, but regular expressions are string equations, not mathematical equations.
While 5 and 05 might have the same mathematical meaning,
our regular expression, which is concerned with strings,
matches this one-letter string "5" but not this two-letter string "05".
Then "9"--well, that's right on the border. We totally match it.
"Isak Dinesen"--we don't match this for a number of reasons.
First, it doesn't contain 0 through 9, and second it's much too long.
"Isak Dinesen" was a pseudonym adopted by Karen Dinesen, a Danish author
who wrote Out of Africa.
Let's imagine that's Africa.
These regular expressions sound super cool,
and I'm going to show you how to use them in Python programs,
but that's going to require one more step.